wealthy people do three things man they
stopped trading time for money
they make their money work for them and
they give as much value to people as
they can
the reason why people think wealthy
people are people with money or Sinister
is because that's what you kind of
taught in the hood like you kind of talk
like
the people who really have money like
they did some Wicked to get it they
did some backstabbing cut those to
get it and you'll never get that all
them people with money they all Crooks
because being at the bottom teaches you
to envy people at the top right one of
the things that happens often in the
culture of black people is survival mode
you never get a chance to play offense
you're always on defense
one because of mindset
because you don't see it again the dope
dealer and the rapper everybody who's
working is struggling and so you never
want to be that